the biggest active wildfire in the u.s
is tearing through drought-stricken
forests in new mexico threatening homes
and forcing thousands of residents to
flee for their lives
by nine o'clock 9 30
the smoke in the valley was so thick he
needed a butter knife to cut through it
so it was it came on really fast
at that point that's when the
law enforcement came up
to tell us to get out
the fires are visible from outer space
firefighters are dropping flame
retardant from helicopters and building
fire breaks with bulldozers
a high school gym has been set up as an
evacuation center
the fire has burned for nearly a month
destroying 300 houses and other
structures
dozens of small towns have been
evacuated in the rugged sangre de cristo
mountains
some residents in las vegas new mexico
east of santa fe have decided to stay
and fight the flames themselves this is
my home
i gotta predict it
i went down my property you know the
hose
the weather forecast doesn't hold out
much hope there's some bad winds coming
up
wednesday night
thursday really really strong
so it was uh if they don't contain it by
wednesday
we're going to be in real trouble
large new fires also broke out in
arizona and several other states
according to u.s agencies wildfires have
burned more than twice as much land this
year as in the same period of 2021
rob reynolds al jazeera